[Music]
on April 23 2006 a man in his early 20s
was seen in Kiev Ukraine staring at a
high-rise apartment building Witnesses
described him as looking confused and
anxious they thought he might have been
a lost tourist the man approached two
police officers and nervously asked for
directions to a place that didn't exist
the officers asked the young man for
identification but there were two
problems with his ID one his documents
were issued by the Soviet Union which no
longer existed the second problem
according to his birth date this young
man was born in 1932.
foreign
a Russian documentary called the time
traveler told the story of Sergey
panamerenko a man who seemed to be
slipping in and out of time eyewitnesses
first saw panamerenko standing at an
intersection in cave looking confused
and a little frightened he was described
as being in his early 20s and wearing
clothes that looked new but were 50
years out of fashion panamerenko was
asking everyone he met how to get to
peshnaya street but nobody heard of it
his strange Behavior caught the
attention of police officer Sergey
annapenko and his partner who approached
him again panamerenko wanted directions
to peshnaya Street when he tried to find
the street on a map all that was there
was a landfill officer anapanco now took
notice of sergey's vintage clothing that
looked brand new he noticed that Sergey
was wearing an antique camera around his
neck which also looked new but what
really caught the police officer's
attention was sergey's identification
according to the document Sergey was
born in Kiev in 1932 that should make
him 74 years old but here he was looking
older than 2 25. what surprised me most
was his identification papers the papers
were dated 1958 but they were like new
it was a photograph that looked similar
to this man but I didn't see how it
could be him
I assume this person was out of his mind
and had to get him to a psychiatrist
Sergey panamerenko didn't want to see a
psychiatrist but his options were that
or be arrested for vagrancy and Easy
Choice so Sergey was taken to a private
Psychiatric clinic where everything is
captured on video and that's when things
get really strange
foreign
KO didn't want to go to a psychiatric
Clinic you can see him on CCTV acting
agitated and nervous the receptionist
said when he arrived he became even more
confused
I remember he kept looking at my mobile
phone just staring at it
he didn't want to give me his code or
his camera or any of his belongings
I knew he was going to be a difficult
patient compared to the picture at the
time of his disappearance he hasn't aged
at all but even more strange is the
background of the photograph you can see
the mother motherland statue over
sergey's right shoulder there's no
question that this is Kiev investigators
went to the exact spot where Sergey took
the picture they found the location but
the rest of the skyline is wrong kieve
doesn't have all those skyscrapers at
least not yet on the back of the
photograph was a message to Valentina
written in sergey's on hand
dearest Valentina everything is fine
with me I'll try to return When I can
yours Sergey it would seem that Sergey
panamerenko had jumped into the future
once again but considering how big Keith
looks in the photos and given what the
city has endured recently there's no way
to tell just how far into the future
sergeys traveled but it's obviously
pretty far as of 2011 when this
documentary was released Sergey had not
reached out to Valentina nor was he
spotted anywhere in the city so if we're
going to solve this mystery we're
apparently gonna have to wait a long
long time
the concept of time travel has been a
staple of Science Fiction for a long
time in 1770 Louis Sebastian Mercier
wrote the book The Year 2440 where the
hero traveled centuries into the future
A Christmas Carol written by Charles
Dickens in 1843 explored time travel in
both directions but the story that
really kicked off the genre was The Time
Machine written by H.G Wells in 1895 but
those are works of fiction as time
travel really possible and if so how
well we know that traveling into the
future is possible in 1905 Einstein
published his special theory of
relativity Einstein described how moving
clocks tick more slowly than stationary
ones the faster you move the slower time
moves so if you want to travel 100 years
into the future what you do is take a
spaceship that can travel at
99.995 the speed of light then flies
somewhere 50 light years away turn
around and come back on earth a hundred
years have passed but because you were
going so fast the trip only took you a a
year time travel this theory has been
proven in the real world if you put an
extremely accurate clock on a plane and
fly it in the same direction that the
Earth spins when you land that clock
will be slightly behind the clocks on
Earth that's special relativity in 1915
Einstein published the theory of general
relativity this describes gravity as a
geometric property of space-time
otherwise known as four-dimensional
space and how space-time is like a
fabric or Continuum that curves around
whatever matter happens to be present
I'm a word what's up obviously I
understand all this obviously but maybe
dumb it down a little yeah you know not
everyone out there is as smart as a
goldfish well general relativity is a
lot but for the purposes of this episode
it boils down to this the higher the
gravity the slower time moves this is
called gravitational time dilation even
dumber please fine remember in
interstellar there's that scene where
Matthew McConaughey and the crew
know what that's my McConaughey
impression do you have to what
what down you most certainly are
anyway when the crew lands on that
planet near the black hole the gravity
is so severe that for every hour they're
on the planet seven years pass on Earth
unless McConaughey example is
GPS satellites they're about 12 000
miles above the Earth's surface so less
gravity which means time moves faster up
there time on the satellites has to be
adjusted to match the slower moving time
down here on the surface otherwise GPS
wouldn't work but all of that is about
time travel into the future what about
time travel to the Past well that's a
bit more theoretical and controversial
not all physicists believe it's possible
Einstein's theories say it is possible
in theory how it's achieved is by
bending or warping space-time so much
that you can take a shortcut from point
A to point B a shortcut that lets you
move faster than light and if you can
somehow move faster than light and get
space time to wrap around itself like a
cylinder you can travel back in time
in theory your your path through time
like this this is your world line your
path through time you're going toward
the future always but what can happen
here is that the space time is
sufficiently Twisted so that you while
going toward the future all the time yet
Circle back and visit an event in your
own past but doing something like this
would require a tremendous amount of
energy possibly all the energy of an
exploding star now obviously our
civilization can't do this but maybe a
very Advanced civilization could maybe
that type of civilization flies Vehicles
like this
so is that what happened to Sergey
panamerenko when he took a picture of
the UFO did he somehow enter a wormhole
or a tear in the fabric of space-time
well
[Music]
now we've heard the story of Sergey
panamerenko and we've determined that
time travel is theoretically possible so
is this story true
no but every article and video I found
that covers the story seems to be just a
retelling of each other's version of the
story and none of those versions are
right today you learned the real story
because I was able to track down the
original full-length documentary which I
had translated from Russian which wasn't
easy oh I could have done that for you
oh you speak Russian nah everyone knows
that word
another secret of chilak
um okay anyway there are a few things in
the documentary that point to a hoax
first in the credits there is a casting
director but maybe that's for the scenes
that were dramatized fine but the police
officer says Sergey appeared on Tuesday
April 23 2006. the camera in the lobby
says Wednesday April 23rd but they're
both wrong that was actually a Sunday
and during his first visit Sergey tells
the doctor that he was born in June 1932
but his ID says he was born in March
during sergey's Second visit to the
doctor the time is 10 39 a.m April 25th
so the dates and times are all over the
place now you think if you were right in
a time travel story you try to be
correct about the uh you know time I
know that was disappointing next the
picture of Sergey that the police have
on the missing persons report look at
the picture Sergey sends to Valentina
look at his clothes look at his collar
they're the same clothes and his collar
is flipped the same exact way in both
photos this is the same picture his
expressions are different but he's been
digitally aged so the producers probably
did that to make it seem more real but
these are details they probably should
have caught so yeah this story is fake
but still I think it's one of the best
time travel stories I've come across the
actors were convincing and as long as
you don't pay too close attention the
pictures are great so why are we so
fascinated with time travel well I think
it's because time is one of the few
things in our lives that is equal for
everyone and that no one can control no
matter how much wealth or power you may
accumulate eventually time wins time
travel makes us think of the
possibilities of the future of what may
exist after we're gone time travel also
reminds us of the impossibilities of the
past of decisions made of mistakes
regrets how many things in your life
would you go back and change maybe you
wouldn't have said that stupid thing in
class maybe you would have stood up to
that bully in your neighborhood or been
nicer to that nerd on the bus oh stop
reliving your childhood or maybe you
would have taken a chance on that
business idea learned a foreign language
travel the war world but there is a
trick we can play on ourselves to take
back a little bit of control of time
it's something I try to do whenever I
have a difficult decision to make 10
years from now or 20 years from now your
future self is going to think back to
today right now and you're going to have
regrets your future self will say I'd
give anything to go back and make
different choices well you're here now
now is your chance be good to your
future self by Taking Chances by being
Kinder by not sweating the small stuff
because look time eventually runs out
for all of us and when you get to the
end whether that's next year or 50 years
from now you don't want to look back on
your life with regret saying I should
have done this or I wish I did that
don't do that to your future self when
you finally get to the end your only
thought should be man that was a hell of
a ride
thank you so much for hanging out with
us today my name is AJ that's tacklefish
this has been the y-files if you had fun
or learned anything do us a favor and
subscribe share comment like you know
what to do that stuff actually really
helps and like most topics we cover on
this channel today's was recommended by
you so if there's a story you'd like to
see or learn more about go to the
yfiles.com tips and special thanks to
our patrons who make this channel
possible Without You there'd be no
Wi-Fi's and there are some fun perks
coming up for you guys so keep an eye on
the patreon page and look out for my
email and if you'd like to support the
channel consider becoming a member on
patreon or grab something from the Wi-Fi
store you don't want to be lying there
in your guest bed thinking gee I really
wish I bought that lizard people mug no
you don't put it crab cat t-shirt right
you don't want to take a fish stickers
we get it all right that's gonna do it
until next time be safe be kind and know
that you are appreciated
[Music]
thank you
foreign
[Music]